like a business cat scam generally I
think it's the thing I do but it's
unbelievable Twilight QA I can literally
like it just look it's the thing that
most comes that's with me like man when
mommy doesn't come around nice like a
vegetable an optical clarity husband
like my name is Gary B Sabah
[ __ ] I've been telling you
tells us all about yeah
I'll triple a camera pedigree to meet an
official FSOC
putting the work that I'm doing are the
moving furniture
[Music]
[Music]
st. Louis we're here I don't have any
Cardinals on my fantasy team right now
concerning literally right here is where
we lost one of our biggest clients new
guy came in prior that's proxy no I was
going to call though oh well yeah good
to see you hi how are you making sure
[Music]
that Sakarya doesn't meet you in real
pleasure
Oh exactly Robin footage very common
Tobias let me holla back I need to come
field kubbs car Dolph game and take
Brandon
yeah I would love it plan R & R as my
best friend he runs Wine Library oh and
he even got huge cups man I took him to
Game one of the World Series last year
because in case in ninth grade I
promised him if the Cubs ever made the
World Series I take them to the fish
game
and we did it I'm so close it's about
1/5 so instead of basketball Oh mm I
don't take tylenol I don't think it's so
funny everybody thinks like I'm a crack
head because of my energy I don't like I
don't I don't even like it's so intense
I'm so it's so funny how I play out like
I'm always the opposite of people but
like I don't take Adam I'm he's from
European old school like it's like the
only things that go my body like tea and
coffee I guess it's the closest thing
they've got to anything and smell but
like I don't think anything knows
nothing protein and [ __ ] actual work
let my body building up is exactly the
same advice is my business building on
grind no shortcuts
[ __ ] mentally pounding through
discipline clucking speech [ __ ] [ __ ]
Rocky Balboa carry a boulder on your
[ __ ] head in a mountain mulch knowing
[ __ ]
[Music]
from Missouri that's your update these
are my fate this is my favorite social
media content this is for people like
all right man no pleasure house thanks
good real good good man real pleasure to
me the other day
yeah where I don't know I was watching
here I can't believe I remember anything
you're like you said I'm hungry on I
pass an uber twice exactly were twice
and I don't know why I remember it
because I don't even watch TV was I
loved it
one thing will come back oh give it this
is our pie shop what will you go for
give it a speech - yo and YPO and like
about your on a macro kick yeah I got
annoyed that oh you make sure people are
well taken care yeah no we have to do
our work I love it you guys you guys
what Sam is your wrist or we had one so
easy this you need the car I'm a feeling
I'm not sorry short I'm gonna happen
something so I'll take some pros I think
I'll take some ribs because it's just
called Jersey for me
you really [ __ ] up the South 5
location put me directly in the ghetto I
like it though back to my roots while
everybody's at the Four Seasons JW
Marriot [ __ ] melting it like a
[ __ ] boss same in the Hilton it's
just funny it's just like an OG spot
there's all these great hotels now
finally there but Tyler for some reason
doesn't use the resources around him
like Phil and need and DeMaio
he just says [ __ ] on its own and it's
caused me a lot of pain but it's
learning salt learning process no nope I
only want to answer the questions that
people want answers having having this
doesn't matter having questions that you
want to ask is selfish the key to a good
speaker is to bring it to them I think
so
so know whatever I'll create a framework
of like you know that's what this talks
about right
I can talk about thematically stuff
that's top of mind but with a group like
we have you know it's real business talk
right it's not like it's companies it's
like it's good it'll be good
ha ha got it real pleasure thank you so
much thank you yes you're so nice our
club anything I was very pleased that I
hope we get to cross paths one day and I
wish you nothing but the best man and
give a great day totally get it I agree
with you not everybody hits everybody
the same way and I hope serendipity
takes over and allows us to share beer
one day
so maybe get a different perspective we
met a bit he'll throw thanks yeah well
your friends you sure I do but not for a
living I just want the awareness I'm not
there for the economics like like even
the job the guy said you make your money
selling t-shirts like swag or books or
like there's no economics in it it's
exposure it's marketing I mean I don't
want to lose money and I'm thrilled to
like make some but it's
disproportionately not the interesting
part of writing a good book the
interesting part of running a good book
is having somebody email you and
something happens and get good Mexican
food there's like about a hundred
Mexican recipe so this is very Latino
based neighborhood
smells good
oh I love this smell so this is the wood
from the locker room from Wrigley Field
from this last year or two years ago
yeah it was the wood it was the wooden
locker in those top examples winning the
World Series yeah we helped them this is
so cool so there's a b2b and a b2c
component right because this is b2c
stuff consumer stuff yeah yeah but
worked like this right this is our old
dugout wood from the Astros and we turn
it into you know as much in New York but
a bootjack dick you know I'm not a big
New York but definitely like super smart
way to like turn things into collectible
utilitarian instead of just like the
same old stuff everyone did so it's big
I totally understand
it's actually very similar to my core
thesis about marketing which is buying
nostalgic brands and make the modern
take the old and make it extremely new
is super interesting oh cool yeah so
glad we stopped by one what's going on
with the bowling week EXO I bring my
guys over and we got it off in five
minutes art so this is this is all
mostly storage in kind of random area
we've got the our baby right here houses
in a lot of unique ways of so a roll of
UV printer right on just about anything
I love those signs for example we can
print like right now we're printing on
leather that there's a some really
unique Cortana this part is relaxed but
we can even print on thread on felt and
make our own and it
[Music]
pretty cool to the next anybody except
we gotta build a cell that's we got to
do ASAP give that a lot of thought
that's how you'll win I'm not how you
leave I love everything about that
except that one piece I bet you know the
best part is to take that kind of place
you I'm aware what do you think my first
reaction was here look I'm business
captain I'm like a business like
generally I think it's the thing I do
that it's unbelievable I like you eh I
can do little me like it just so 60
thing that most comes out with me or
like okay this we cool right and I've
never said that before that's it's so
weird what just happened what you love
it's us so move it avoid from my voice
one of my brother's best friend - what
the Vayner is like a huge hip-hop head
this what David Lee from battledress set
up a band right now
show them the vein of rookie pitcher
tell the find them interview them that's
probably you know what that's what we
can do over the weekend mmm-hmm go have
them really interview them let's get
somebody charismatic that's like what
did you know about Gary let's get
somebody in it
I have Emily interview like what do you
know about Gary had it happen when did
you see them
did you constantly not coming to see
them how did the interview process come
[Music]
maybe interview Andy and Alex or climb
about how you got to keep a lot of Gary
frogs to actually get a prince again you
know got it
make a poem for architects good
afternoon thanks for having me really
excited to be here
I see the green life to be very frank I
have quite a bit of time up here and
it's been allocated for 25 minutes of
the talk and 45 minutes of QA I'd like
to pretty much inspire maybe even it's
an hour of Q&A because I think the
number one job of the speakers to bring
value to the audience and I think in
this world that we live in a lot of my
thoughts and pieces live online on
YouTube and Facebook and you can get
quite a bit of that see all of your
books
you get quite a bit there I'll set a
framework because I'm sure a lot of
people don't know who I am or what I
believe in and hopefully to be very
honest actually how many people here are
in b2b businesses raise your hand high
awesome how about b2c startups to
consumer raise your hands okay so like I
want to really just get a sense of the
audience so I can take the conversation
in series election and as you can
imagine
[Music]
how many businesses in this room have an
Alexa voice skill strategy for their
business I promise you none yet 100
million Americans in three years will
wake up and say Alexa give me my breath
and some local business is going to be
the one that gives the news the weather
the sports scores why can't that be you
why can't your sports shop be the thing
that gives the local people of st. Louis
their sports scores and then every
single morning the whole goddamn town is
thinking about your business it can't be
you because you wait we're not on the
offense and so that's just three and
four years away and that's not something
you like people people don't even know
what an Alexis EKKO is and the ones that
do here you know their kids are using it
85 percent more than they are right like
where do you think the world is going
there are parents in this room that are
keeping their kids off of technology as
if the kids are going to live up in a
caveman world like what do you think
this is going we're not going backwards
I'm sorry Thank You vinaigrette this
what is one ninja trick used to vet
somebody to be a rock star marketing
ploy I believe in the I got a good one
actually a little bit left field I am a
much bigger believer in firing than
hiring like my whole life has been
predicated on having good EQ and
intuition I have fired so many [ __ ] I've
hired so many [ __ ] people are I
think people are at their best when
they're in interviews you know like you
just can't get anywhere not a complete
non-event right like what do you what's
your biggest what's your biggest
weakness sometimes I just work too hard
[ __ ] so so my biggest trick is actually
not thinking I'm so smart and figuring
it out it's be optimistic give trust
instead of having it earned hire them to
the best of your capabilities but then
audit them aggressively always and get
rid of them when they don't play either
the honey or the Empire part and in my
world that is the kind of internal
politics and HR skills and the skill of
what they're supposed to do people have
so much pride it's unbelievable how many
people in this room have fake ego in how
good they hire so much so that they
don't fire losers because they don't
want that loss to smear their incredible
hiring record that's why most people
build small businesses and every you
know let me just say something about
this audience I'm watching you that was
a really good reaction because a lot of
you know that was real [ __ ] truth
right there that was good and then guys
all of my stuff is cycle it's all humans
that's what we screw up everything like
we're screwing it up like it's on us you
can't hire a twenty eight forty to sixty
year old marketer and just outsource it
to them when it's your business because
you're never done gonna and trust them
because you don't know the skill that's
why you're not doing new stuff because
you don't know if she or he is right or
wrong because you don't know and instead
just go to Turks and Caicos and listen
to free audiobooks and you're good like
you'll have some foundation it's crazy
to me it's crazy to me but I love it
like I'm so pumped a lot of you are
going to go out of business when the
[ __ ] melts no I'm happy cuz that's
actually capitalize 'm that's actual
meritocracy that's how this goes you
deserve to leave you can complete them
for 11 years you're finished you suck
I really focus on what I'm good at HR
selling the strategy and then I really
leave everything else to other people
because I know maybe they won't be as
good as me or this at me but I just know
what I'm good at and I will tell you
like the reason I've been really
successful book writing is when I
thought that I had to write the book I
didn't even consider it when I reverse
engineered what I was good at which was
talking my ass off and realized there
were ghost writers that could help me do
the other part I got really good you
just have to be dangerous enough I'm not
a CFO driven entrepreneur right but I
will buy the New York Jets for billions
of billions of dollars I just have to be
dangerous enough to not allow my CFO's
to put me out of business
so figure out what you need to be
dangerous at check your ego at the door
and quadruple down on your strengths
that is the historic nature of people
that have built very large successful
enterprises thank you for having me
[Applause]
the brands have been commoditized so
they need the personal brand new while a
lot of the umbrella companies they play
within are handcuffing them on social
because they're scared of regulations
because they didn't read the responses
of the regulations so that's what I
think Seton Hall baby-baby Marquette
let's go halt
the only college basketball team I've
ever liked the bandwagon run of 89 so
fun
small Jersey school going to the file 89
to like 94 lightweight but that 89 run
was like magic I was 14 and 6 double a
small Jersey school final for the crush
pink like it was crazy
Oh
[Music]
you
ah
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]